hey what's up guys it's Marcus Brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome back to
another high-definition video tutorial
and welcome back to a familiar interface
this one being of Safari 5 as you can
see by the title today we'll be going
over Safari 5 extensions you may already
know that chrome 5 has extensions and
Firefox has something called add-ons and
floc uses Chrome extensions and really
Safari was the only main browser next
Internet Explorer which is obviously not
something we want to look up to that's
missing extensions of some sort so I'm
going to show you how to enable them and
where to get them so to enable
extensions in Safari first go to your
little settings bar up here and go to
preferences this dialog box will pop up
and you want to hit show developer menu
in menu bar then X out of that then
you'll hit alt if you don't already have
your menu bar and go to that develop
button and go ahead and tick enable
extensions and that's all you have to do
to enable extensions in Google Chrome or
I'm sorry in Safari 5 alright so now
that you've enabled extensions in Safari
5 I'm going to show you how and where to
install them so I have in this notepad
document right here a link to a tumblr
blog that has a lot of examples Safari 5
extensions so go ahead and paste that
and visit the link and they have a whole
bunch of them featured on their home
page I'm going to go ahead and search
adblock just because it's the it happens
to be the the extension that I use the
most or enjoy the most or add wart in
chrome I've been using chrome for a
while and like I said I wanted to give
Safari 5 a try I tweeted it out I wanted
to switch to it and I just didn't really
get to know it enough and I kind of
think that extensions will be the thing
that finally hooks me so click here to
get the download link if there's ever a
download link for an extension that's
what you want to click and hit open so
you're going to get a dialog box very
similar to what you got in Google Chrome
that says are you sure you want to
install the extension install our don't
install well hit install of course
because we want to use this and just
like that we can see up here and block
has been installed so we'll go ahead and
close the download window so that's just
as quick as it gets to install a safari
5 extension you can go ahead and drag it
around move it wherever you
we can visit an example page just to
make sure it works obviously the New
York Times site will have typically have
ads on it so there you go there are no
ads on this New York Times site so there
it is guys that's how you install
extensions in Safari 5 I hope you
enjoyed this video
nothing intended here by having the
Google home page but I just wanted to
show you guys what you could do with
Safari 5 so thanks for watching this
video and I'll talk to you guys in the
next one peace